imagine the vast Fields stretching out
as far as the eye can see where
thousands of hands work tirelessly Under
the Sun to harvest an astounding amount
of vegetables from crisp lettuce to
Juicy Tomatoes the process of bringing
these fresh veggies from the Earth to
your plate is nothing short of
incredible but how does this massive
operation work today we're pulling back
the curtain on the fascinating world of
American Farm Workers and revealing the
secrets behind how millions of tons of
vegetables are harvested each year
buckle up as we explore the high-tech
Machinery the hard work and the
challenges that shape this crucial part
of our food system vegetable farming in
the United States is a colossal industry
producing millions of tons of fresh
produce each year from the Rolling
fields of California to the green houses
of Florida American Farms Supply a
significant portion of the nation's
vegetables contributing to both local
markets and Global exports this
extensive network of farms is essential
not only for feeding the country but
also for supporting countless jobs and
fueling the agricultural economy the
scale of this operation is staggering
involving vast amounts of land resources
and labor to ensure that fresh
vegetables are available year round in
this video will delve into the intricate
process behind harvesting these
vegetables uncovering the blend of human
effort and technological innovation that
makes it all possible we'll explore the
methods Farm Workers use from manual
picking to sophisticated machinery and
discuss the challenges they face such as
labor shortages and economic pressures
by understanding the technology and
techniques involved we'll gain a greater
appreciation for the hard work that goes
into getting those crisp vegetables onto
our plates before starting this video
please like this video And subscribe to
our channel the harvesting process
before the first vegetable is harvested
meticulous preh Harvest preparation is
crucial this starts with soil and crop
management practices designed to ensure
optimal growing conditions Farmers test
soil quality and adjust nutrients to
create a fertile environment for plants
crop rotation is also used to maintain
soil health and prevent pest buildup
seasonal planning plays a significant
role as well Farmers consider the timing
of planting and harvesting to align with
seasonal weather patterns ensuring that
crops are picked at their peak of
ripeness weather considerations
including temperature and rainfall are
carefully monitored to prevent issues
like frost damage or excessive moisture
that could affect the yield and quality
of the produce certain vegetables such
as tomatoes lettuce and peppers are
typically harvested by hand due to their
delicate nature or the Precision
required manual harvesting involves
workers carefully picking the produce to
avoid damage and ensure quality this
process is labor intensive and requires
significant skill as workers must
identify the right ripeness level and
handle each vegetable gently Farm
Workers often share stories of their
daily tasks highlighting the physical
demands and the camaraderie developed
among the crew their experiences
underscore the dedication and hard work
involved in maintaining the high
standards required for Fresh Market
vegetables in contrast to manual
harvesting mechanized harvesting has
revolutionized the efficiency and speed
of the process modern harvesting
machines such as combine Harvesters and
specialized vegetable Pickers have been
designed to handle large volumes of
produce with greater Precision these
machines can perform tasks like cutting
sorting and packing significantly
reducing the need for manual labor for
instance combined Harvesters are
equipped to efficiently gather crops
like corn and wheat while specialized
Pickers are tailored for vegetables like
carrots and
potatoes this mechanization helps Farms
manage larger operations and meet the
high demand for
vegetables advancements in technology
have further enhanced the harvesting
process gpsg guided equipment for
example allows for precise navigation
and field mapping optimizing harvesting
roots and reducing wasted time automated
systems equipped with sensors can detect
the ripeness of fruits and veget
ensuring that only produce at the ideal
stage is harvested these technological
innovations not only improve efficiency
but also contribute to better crop
management and reduced labor costs by
integrating these Technologies Farms can
achieve higher productivity and better
manage their
resources despite the advantages of
mechanization there are still
significant challenges in the harvesting
process labor shortages are a major
issue as the demand for skilled workers
often exceeds the supply this shortage
can lead to delays and increased costs
impacting the overall efficiency of
harvesting
operations additionally economic
pressures such as fluctuating market
prices and Rising operational costs pose
further challenges Farms must
continually adapt to these pressures by
finding innovative solutions and
improving their practices I es to remain
competitive looking ahead the future of
vegetable harvesting will likely
continue to evolve with technological
advancements Innovations such as robotic
Harvesters and Aid driven analytics
promis to further enhance efficiency and
precision as the industry faces ongoing
challenges including labor shortages and
economic
fluctuations the integration of new
technologies will play a crucial role in
in sustaining and advancing vegetable
harvesting
practices these developments will ensure
that Farms can continue to meet the
growing demand for fresh produce while
addressing the complexities of modern
agricultural practices before moving
forward make sure you like this video
And subscribe to our Channel technology
and
Innovation recent advancements in
harvesting technology have significantly
transformed the way vegetables are
collected from Fields Innovations in
Machinery such as automated Harvesters
and advanced sorting systems have
greatly improved efficiency and
productivity modern Harvesters are now
equipped with sophisticated sensors and
algorithms that allow them to detect and
pick vegetables with high Precision for
example robotic arms and conveyor belts
in some systems can handle delicate
produce like tomatoes without causing
damage than thanks to their Gentle Touch
and adaptive
technology these advancements not only
speed up the harvesting process but also
reduce the Reliance on manual labor
addressing some of the industry's labor
shortages the rise of Automation in
robotics has had a profound impact on
vegetable harvesting automation has
streamlined many aspects of the process
from planting and monitoring crops to
the actual harvesting robotics can now
perform tasks that were previously
manual and labor intensive such as
removing weeds or sorting vegetables
based on size and ripeness these
Technologies enhance overall efficiency
and allow Farms to manage larger volumes
of produce with fewer workers moreover
the use of drones and aerial Imaging
provides real-time data on crop health
and growth enabling more targeted and
effective harvesting
strategies data and analytics have also
become crucial in farming helping to
optimize harvesting schedules and
techniques by collecting and analyzing
data on weather conditions soil health
and crop yields farmers can make
informed decisions that maximize their
productivity the integration of AI and
machine learning further enhances
Precision farming by predicting crop
performance and identifying the best
times for harvesting these Technologies
can analyze vast amounts of data to
forecast yield Quant quantities detect
potential issues and recommend
adjustments to improve
outcomes together these advancements not
only make vegetable harvesting more
efficient but also pave the way for
smarter datadriven
agriculture challenges faced by Farm
Workers the physical demands of
harvesting vagetables are substantial
and often grueling Farm Workers endure
long hours Under the Sun performing
repetitive tasks that can lead to
physical strain and
fatigue activities such as bending
lifting and carrying heavy loads require
significant physical strength and
endurance this strenuous work can result
in musculoskeletal injuries and other
health issues if proper ergonomics and
safety practices are not followed
training programs and safety measures
are crucial to minimizing these risks
teaching workers proper lifting
techniques and ensuring they use
appropriate protective gear despite
these efforts the physical toll of the
job remains a significant challenge for
those involved in vegetable
harvesting labor shortages represent
another major challenge for the
vegetable farming industry many farms
rely heavily on seasonal and migrant
workers and recent years have seen a
decline in the availability of these
labor sources factors contrib ruting to
this shortage include immigration policy
changes lower wages and the increasing
difficulty of farm work the impact of
these shortages is profound leading to
reduced harvests and increased costs in
response the industry has been exploring
various Solutions such as improving
working conditions offering better wages
and investing in labor saving
Technologies government policies and
worker programs aimed at addressing
these shortages also play a critical
role in supporting the industry and
ensuring a stable
Workforce economic pressures add an
additional layer of complexity to the
harvesting process fluctuating market
prices for vegetables can affect the
profitability of farming operations
influencing decisions about which crops
to grow and when to harvest Rising costs
for inputs such as fuel labor and
equipment further strain Farmers budgets
to navigate these economic challenges
both Farm Workers and Farmers must adapt
by optimizing their practices and
finding ways to reduce costs without
compromising quality strategies might
include adopting more efficient
harvesting Technologies diversifying
Crop Production or negotiating better
prices with Buyers by remaining flexible
and proactive the agricultural sector
strives to manage these pressures and
sustain its vital role in the food
supply chain in summary the process of
harvesting vegetables in America is a
remarkable feat that combines tradition
with
Innovation the Journey Begins With
meticulous pre Harvest preparation where
soil and crop management set the stage
for a successful yield manual harvesting
remains crucial for delicate crops while
mechanized harvesting driven by advanced
technology enhances efficiency and speed
the latest advancements including
Automation and Robotics are
revolutionizing the industry enabling
Farmers to meet High demands while
reducing labor
intensity despite these technological
strides the challenges faced by Farm
Workers are significant the physical
demands of the job coupled with labor
shortages and economic pressures create
a complex landscape that requires
ongoing adaptation and resilience
training safety measures and innovative
solutions are essential in addressing
these challenges and ensuring the
industry can continue to thrive as you
enjoy a fresh vegetable remember the
incredible efforts that go into bringing
it from the field to your table from the
cuttingedge Machinery that speeds up the
process to the dedication of
hard-working individuals who labor Under
the Sun the the Journey of vegetables is
a testament to the Ingenuity and
perseverance of American
agriculture next time you take a bite
take a moment to appreciate the
extraordinary efforts that make it all
possible if you found this behind the
scenes look at the Incredible World of
vegetable harvesting fascinating we'd
love to hear from you don't forget to
hit that like button share this video
with your friends and family and
subscribe to our channel for more
in-depth insights into the world of
Agriculture and beyond your support
helps us bring you more content that
dives deep into the stories and
Technologies shaping our food systems
but don't go just yet stay tuned for our
next video where we'll explore the
latest trends in sustainable farming
practices and how they're transforming
the future of
Agriculture plus we have exciting
content lined up on the role of
technology in modern farming and
profiles of inspiring figures in the
agricultural industry make sure you're
subscribed and have notifications turned
on so you don't miss any of these
exciting updates thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video